[Musique]
carmine russo bonjour bonjour bonjour
monsieur partie bonjour à toutes les
auditrices et tous les auditeurs de
martinique 1ère vous conduisait la liste
françois w vous êtes soutenus par le
mouvement bas pays en chasse en plus de
votre appartenance politique locale très
large vous arrivé en troisième position
on
juste un petit bug oui mais mon chrono
dans une mousse au bonjour bonjour
monsieur partie bonjour à toutes les
auditrices et tous les auditeurs de
martinique première et en particulier
aux franciscains duo francis cas bien
évidemment vous conduisait la liste fera
sans doute que vous êtes soutenus par le
mouvement bas payé un chanceux présidée
par yan monplaisir en plus de votre
appartenance politique locale très lent
je vous êtes arrivé en troisième
position du premier tour de scrutin le
15 mars
vous avez réalisé 979 fois si près de
16% après à l'écolo delà gier et samuel
tavernier et avant françois christophe
urios eu des électeurs grenet quelle est
votre lecture des résultats de ce
premier tour on va écouter ça a été en
scrutin très compliqué vu les conditions
sanitaires et je veux d'ailleurs
remercié les presque mille électeurs qui
malgré tout se sont déplacés et ont mis
l'équipe françois doz boot en lice pour
ce deuxième tour le 28 juin
ce que je veux leur dire c'est que ce 28
juin tout est possible c'est une
nouvelle élection qui commence on est
restés tous trois mois à réfléchir chez
nous à l'avenir certainement et je pense
que les franciscains franciscaine on
réfléchit aussi à l'avenir de leur
commune le franc soit le 28 juin c'est
une nouvelle élection
les compteurs sont remis à zéro et tout
est possible onze mille électeurs
franciscain ne se sont pas déplacés aux
urnes c'est énorme
et parmi ces onze mille nous pensons
qu'il y a des gens qui comme nous comme
moi palais ni eux ni lot et on
expliquera pourquoi pendant la campagne
qu'est-ce qui vous empêchait de
fusionner avec l'un des deux candidats
arrivés en tête ou de vous désister sa
consigne de voir puisque vous arrive en
troisième position
tout comme en 2014 pourquoi avoir
réédité 7
7,7 ce soir écouter parce que notre
position est très claire nous ce que
nous voulons c'est le vrai changement
françois nous voulons gagner la mairie
du françois avec l'équipe françois doz
boot
nous ne voulons pas remettre une équipe
qui est là depuis 25 ans avec un piètre
bilan et nous ne voulons pas non plus
d'une autre équipe qui vient finalement
par vengeance par je dirais attrait du
pouvoir ou haine des autres
une équipe qui diviserait à nouveau le
peuple franciscain nous ce que nous
voulons à françois doz boots et
rassembler les franciscains nous pas les
nids en hillotte nous nous maintenons
avec une offre politique qui est formé
de d'hommes et de femmes compétents
compétentes et surtout de conviction
alors c'est pour ça que je dis aux
franciscains des franciscains de passer
le relais à cette nouvelle équipe
l'équipe du vrai changement dose est une
femme déterminée honnêtes compétents ils
m'ont vu à l'oeuvre à la collectivité
territoriale et le 28 juin de faire le
choix de françois doz beauté du vrai
changement
alors si les franciscains et les
franciscains vous choisi si vous êtes
élu maire de la ville qu'elle le sera le
premier projet caoutchouc qui vous tient
que vous souhaiteriez mettre en oeuvre
au plus vite alors des projets
évidemment on en a beaucoup on a quatre
axes en gros c'est vrai que si je devais
parler d'un projet parce que la crise
qu'ovide 19 nous a fait penser encore
plus qu'avant
c'est ce but social que nous voulons
mettre en place au françois
c'est à dire un bus qui ira dans les
quartiers car nous voulons revenir dans
les quartiers dans ce but il y aura des
élus il y aura une infirmière y aura
certainement un juriste ou une avocate
des gens qui pourront aider la
population est allé au plus près d'eux
et c'est vrai que pendant cette crise on
s'est dit mince on n'est pas encore au
pouvoir parce que ce but social qu'est
ce qu'il aurait été utile d'aller voir
les gens dans les quartiers des
personnes isolées qui peuvent pas se
déplacer qu'ils peuvent pas venir pour x
y raison à la mairie nous irons vers eux
nous retournerons dans les quartiers et
puis évidemment nous avons des projets
pour le développement économique et
touristique vous savez que je commence à
me connaître en développement
touristique
voilà nous avons des projets pour que le
françois soit enfin
au niveau de son potentiel c'est
important et enfin pour terminer notre
entretien comment vous organisez vous
avec votre équipe du pont cette campagne
de second tour ont vu les conditions
sanitaires plutôt contraignante très
contraignante on est encore dans une
situation difficile nous ce qu'on veut
dire aux franciscains des franciscains
c'est de se rassurer de ne pas avoir
peur de venir voter le 28 juin toutes
les conditions seront bonnes mises en
place pour qu'il n'y ait aucun risque
d'ailleurs nous nous mêmes françois
dubout tu nous mettrons des masques à
disposition des franciscaines
franciscains qui viendront voter nous
espérons pour françois doz boot
c'est vrai que c'est une campagne
compliquée mais à travers les réseaux
sociaux c'est ce que nous avons fait
pendant pendant le confinement nous
arrivons atteindre un maximum de
personnes nous ferons nous utiliserons
évidemment les voitures sono pour aller
parler un peu expliqué notre programme
et puis les franciscains franciscaine
aurons notre programme à nouveau dans
leur boîte aux lettres la semaine
prochaine
en tout cas on ne lâche rien fait
confiance à l'équipe françois dubout tu
oses est le vrai changement aux et une
femme compétente déterminé à votre
service merci quand ils m'ont sûr
d'avoir première cet autre qui est
réalisé par joe louis bongo
[Musique]